[Music]
you've already won an Emmy so is this
just like the icing on the cake if you
can win today I love getting to have a
party with my friends we work together
in a soundstage all day long but here we
get to come out and have some fun why do
people love your show so much I think
it's something to relate to for
everybody for the people who never felt
like they fit in or didn't look right or
didn't feel right this is a place where
everybody is accepted I mean because
people love the show
they love to quote it they love to make
memes they love to go crazy but here's
the question how much longer can you do
it I've been doing this for a long time
I have I'm not very precious about this
business if they have face if they have
a check I'll be doing it does it also
say something about and you look at the
way this country is now does it say
something that people love this show and
it shows that there's a diverse world
out there yeah I mean I think people in
the early days they didn't understand
what is a drag queen even but now they
they watch and they see it's really just
people artists expressing themselves and
I think that's universal people that
understand what it's like to stand on a
stage and do your thing and want to do
it well there's a lot of expression on
the show people love to express
themselves and that's what makes it so
much fun all right tonight your
expectations of Stephen Colbert cuz I I
sense it'll get a little political he's
so funny I just love him
politics politics I'm here for a good
time aren't you always always all right
real quick car that that track it makes
you feel Oh celebratory the dress makes
you feel rich that jacket roughly like
RuPaul and that suit makes me feel like
Diana Ross
in mahogany or would it be something
later I'm gonna say mahogany